foreign
[Music]
I am so happy to see a packed house I'm
so excited you all are here to um hear
our live it is unscripted there's you
know no Bard no code chat bison
generating the responses we're going to
have a discussion today about how AI
what we expect in the future how will
change every stage of the software
development life cycle so that's not
good
who all do we have in the audience
[Applause]
so who all do we have in the audience
who's a who's a developer or an engineer
okay awesome do we have any uh SRE
devops folks
ml engineers
okay awesome we're gonna have a broad
conversation so I hope everyone takes
something fun away so let's actually get
started my name is anushree vastava I
will be your pilot on today's flight I'm
gonna let all of these folks introduce
themselves starting with me Kelly then
I'll uh say my background and then we'll
get started with the questions so
introduce yourself but also add
something fun what was the first
software development tool that you
really had to have to know or what's
your favorite
all right let's do this hi everyone I'm
Michael catastra I lead the AI team at
rapid and the first developer tool I've
ever used in my life is a basic Rebel so
I think it's fate for me to be working
at rapid for everyone Rebel is a really
loud print Loop and I think I was a very
small kid back in the days
uh yeah so uh Adam Jones uh working G
appliances leading the cloud engineering
iot teens there uh you know uh
first tool that I would really like to
use was
the very first version of Visual Studio
nice way back you know I'm dating myself
but yeah so
hi my name is Erwin I'm one of the
director of program management at Google
around vertex
and I'll skip the tool question because
if I talk about basic programming I'm
telling you too much about my age
so I just said that I relate to this
because it reminds me of a big
transformation in one of the startups I
was leading a few years ago when we
moved from on-prem
waterfall into Cloud agile with some
containers and I had Fortune 500
customers trusting us to do that so I'm
very excited about this conversation
this afternoon
great awesome so I'm Richard I do
product management and developer
relations and
First Tool I am a political science
major so I have no business working at
Google I guess but I was also doing some
webmaster stuff in college and we're
using FileMaker Pro as a back end so
that was the first thing I had some fun
with in the 90s oh nice I am going to
date myself thank you
my name is anushree vastava so I am one
of the leads for Applied AI advocacy
team here at Google I've actually been
at Google for almost 10 years the first
half of my career I was actually a
software engineer on our famous maybe
Infamous developer experience tool stack
so you know back then we just couldn't
have predicted the opportunities that we
have now with these generative models so
I'm really excited to kick this off so
you all ready let's do it okay great
okay uh let's go over actually uh to set
the context this is a software
development life cycle uh we'll
reference this again you know as we go
on but the stages are requirements
Gathering design coding testing
deployment maintenance and then last but
not least retirement
we're good at that one
so let's actually warm up so this is a
warm-up question
so what do you see the impact of AI
assistance and tooling powered by AI
where do you see the biggest impacts in
the short term and then follow-up what
do you aspire to see in the long term
who wants to go first
um well I'll take a shot huh um
so for me you know my teams
um generative AI
specifically has been a real game
changer
um
and we you know earlier
this year I
sat with the team I said hey you know
what let's do a hackathon and let's just
dissect the sdlc and let's figure out
what we can do with Junior AI right
we saw a real impact particularly as you
shift left on that sdlc right you look
at business requirements together you
know one of the I'm sure everybody in
this room has that problem of Gathering
business requirements from the business
and translating those into the technical
requirements to start work right it's
just this process that can become very
impactful and lengthen your your
development time so
you know we we started injecting uh
generative AI capabilities into that
process right away
I think we're going to see 10 20 30
percent productivity improvements out of
that you don't have to mention the rest
of the cycle but really really excited
about those kind of capabilities that
we're seeing on General AI
great
anybody want to add to anything because
I'd say I mean the short term I think
it's going to complement what we do I
think the long term it changes what we
do like in the short term right we're
just doing our existing processes but
with some you know sprinkle some AI on
it and that'll be helpful it helps us do
the same coding or testing processes
design but I think what we're seeing
that this is going to maybe even happen
faster than we think that then after
that long term we probably don't even do
some of the same things we're doing now
like then it's not complimenting it
actually can replace certain things get
rid of toil so for the next you know 12
18 months hopefully it just makes all of
our jobs a little better hopefully in 18
to 24 months it makes our job a little
different awesome
let's go to our next question
so now we're going to go into the
software development life cycle so every
great project starts with an idea right
so where can we see AI influencing the
ideation stage brainstorming Gathering
requirements wireframing all of that
so when we chatted a little bit last
week to get to know each other I heard
the story at GE Appliances on
requirements
and you know the product line I deal
with it's about the model and helping
you code completion and what
and this is before in the cycle so I
tested the idea in a bunch of
conversation since then and I think it's
it's pretty huge because there's a lot
of friction that is experienced there
and maybe you can converge faster on on
requirements so I would just encourage
everybody to take a look it sounds
really promising although it's not in
the code development phase per se
but what really excited me like at the
keynote uh
you guys announced the extensions right
extensions into jira and Confluence so
my team we actually wrote
that before you guys had uh released
that so we're pretty excited about it I
was talking to my team we're like hey
next week we're wiring that up so that's
very exciting
Kelly you got any thoughts on this now
one thing I like about putting AI in
this software especially in the you know
wireframing and brainstorming cycle is
the fact that it helps you to avoid the
writer block as we are seeing you know
for writers the same thing happens with
software right so you have a you have a
companion that you can chat with even
before you start to run your first line
of code so the AI cannot be to figure
out okay these are all the options in
front of you where do you want to go and
then it can also help you to split into
different subtasks your project I've
seen people using in that way I found it
fascinating I think I'm too opinionated
as a developer and I love to see younger
people having a conversation with an nlm
to figure out exactly what they should
be doing so I expect this to happen more
and more often in the future
yeah I would say the brainstorming I was
watching one of my colleagues the other
day do uh you could take a diagram right
now if you use our architecture
diagramming tool if you've seen that
it's free you can build some really cool
diagrams with that you can save it as an
image send it to Bard and say hey can
you find any security risks with this
and it'll go ahead and give you some
things I think for brainstorming
figuring out requirements it's kind of
cool to use AI to assess your
architecture for you and you can discard
all the recommendations but it might
give you something interesting if you
hadn't thought about same with
wireframing that I love about you I'm
terrible at you eyes and so what I also
tried even with Bard is just giving it
the description of my Json payload
saying hey can you give me a front end
and I could add some data and call that
API and it gave me a full HTML CSS
bootstrap UI so again if I'm just trying
to wireframe quick I don't want to do
all that like that's amazing so if
you're just doing some brainstorming
trying to get some ideas I love that
these things are helping us with that
yeah I'm glad that you brought up you
know having security considerations
earlier in the life cycle there is you
know a whole host of these one of our
what are our deployment considerations
whatever scaling considerations what's
our documentation if we can pull some of
these questions earlier in the life
cycle I think that that could be really
revolutionary
definitely
okay next question
okay this is a little bit of a long one
so how do you see the role of software
developer changing as AI permeates all
of these stages of software development
then follow-up
what tasks are now automatable that
weren't and where do you see this going
you know what I see you smiling yeah
yeah the reason why it's modding is
because I believe AI is not going to
only change the role of the software
developer is going to change who
software developers are
um we've been talking at the beginning
about this sort of vertical expansion of
skills so developers will become more
productive more capable I think what I'm
excited about and what we're excited
about the rapid is also the horizontal
expansion the idea that I think today we
have maybe 30 40 million developers in
the world that don't call me on the exam
number and we can see them we should see
the number expanding very quickly to
hundreds of millions or one billion plus
so we probably have to reconsider what
is this software developer Persona that
we Target today one year away from five
years from today and that's the part
that I find and most exciting about this
revolution in calling
yeah for yeah it's good and for me you
know
one of the things that's that's changing
immediately is
skill set capabilities within software
developers right so
what six months ago nine months ago
you're interviewing somebody you know
you're writing a job description for
especially for leaders out there you're
trying to you know resource your roles
what were you looking for right the
traditional set of skills from whatever
you were trying to identify right now ai
has been injected into every single one
of those job descriptions it's
particularly generative AI what are you
doing with general of AI those are the
first questions that we're asking people
now are you playing with it how are you
playing with it how are you using it I
think you're going to see that change
across the board as far as you know what
what the skill sets are they're
developing
yeah
I guess I
I'd say that there's a reason why uh we
have better technology than ever now we
seem to be working more than our parents
like how is that we should be working
less right but I think it's because the
expectations keep going up and so our
expectations are higher than they were
50 years ago and so the role is going to
change because everyone's expectation of
you is about to change it's going to be
expected that you have great test
coverage all over because it's not as
hard to add tests to your code and that
you can iterate a little faster because
we can generate code to kind of
experiment faster so maybe the role
won't change a ton but I think the
expectations of all of you will go up on
us as well and that's exciting
terrifying and at the same time but I
suspect that's what we're going to feel
the most yeah I mean I definitely don't
think any of these roles are going away
they'll just change right there's an art
to setting up testing infrastructure so
it was an art to you know doing your
production deployments
um that I'll say it I'm on camera I I
don't think that AI can really replicate
you know the human spirit yet so uh
hopefully I'm I'm not wrong but we'll
it's in beta but no
it's close I'm glad that you brought up
hiring I was actually I was trying to
think of a way to sort of trick one of
you all to doing a whiteboard interview
so
um great so let's go on to our next
question
so we talked about how AI will shift the
role of what we think of as software
developers right now software Engineers
software developers let's actually
broaden this discussion now let's think
about we touched a little bit on this
you know how is it going to change you
know SRE qa's Tech writer system
integrators how we think about
architecture
and um
flip side you know there's a lot of
Focus right now on the coding stage of
the software development cycle what are
other parts that are not being thought
of right now that we we think that AI
could really impact
yeah so a lot of conversations around
generating tests I think that's
definitely something where it can help
but above and beyond the list of tasks
where it can help I'm really wondering
how do we integrate this in the workflow
of the developer because eventually if
you need to go out of your context to
get some additional help you may do it a
few times but are you going to bring
this back so I think we need to it's
important to understand where this thing
can help but also how we are we bringing
this in a way that's very natural for
the developer to use as opposed to
playing it five times
and I'm sure we stopped seeing I mean we
can read the first stats on which areas
of the cycle are the most impacted but
there is more to be looked at outside of
code generation competition to really
understand how making the effort of
integrating that so is do you have your
own ID and you want an API or are you
going to rely on a third party to renew
that inclusive experience but if you
look at similar revolutions prior
it's all about making this easy for
developer to follow
it's great but if it's for a few people
who have the time or the patience to
switch context all the time it's not
going to make the changes we just talked
about
yeah and I I like you know seeing the
integration of these tools like what
we're seeing you all are announcing
right again back to my hackathon we
built 19 built a whole bunch of custom
capabilities
leveraging bar leveraging text bison
leveraging these models Etc to help us
in the sdlc right various stages devops
was one of them because like for example
uh you know generate me a bunch of
terraform scripts right and one cool
thing we did we went out the bar and
we're like I just went out there I was
like hey
um you know I got this idea for an app
this API you know I want to do this I
want to do that right
how do I do this can you give me an
architecture it did hey what services do
I use in gcp it told me that right it
started setting all this up for me
okay how much time do we spend sitting
there thinking about that writing the
scripts that we need Etc
um
can we can we shorten that cycle right
and then just become like we talked
about how are the role of the software
developer going to change
how much time are you going to not spend
thinking about that thing anymore and
just looking at what was outputted and
vetting it and saying go
how much faster can we get delivery to
Market
how many of y'all have ever been
frustrated with how many times you have
to switch contacts just to get something
done
so everyone else is a liar
all right
I have a controversial take to add I
think one year there is going to be
disrupted by Ai and we're not discussing
it too much is the No code experience
it's controversial for the following
reason I think we always associate no
code to actually not writing a single
line of code but the difference there is
usually those platforms have offer like
a very rigid experience on how you
develop software and there was a I think
our entry point to bring development to
people that are not experts and I think
AI is going to lower the barrier of
entries so much that a lot of people
will feel more courageous to try to use
platform where you actually write some
code or at least you see the AI
generating it and you try to make sense
of it I've seen this in person during
agathons I think is one of the best
experience that you can have as an AI
software developer to figure out how
people use our tools like in the case of
Rapid we do this on a regular basis
because we want to see our users what's
their impact on the platform and I've
seen a lot of people who say one year
ago would be using our no code platform
where now there more daring because they
know that there is an AI and building
them during the software development
process so no codas are space in the
world absolutely but I think you know
this expansion of adding more users
writing software will happen also
because it's less scary
yes he was an AI yeah
I mean I'd say for each of these if you
don't see how generative AI may impact
it you're maybe not thinking hard enough
like all of these feel like they've got
some impact if I'm a tester I don't
think I ever need to hand generate test
data again I can go these tools and
generate 10 000 rows of something and
immediately have test data if I'd like
to an architect as we talked about
earlier could generate and test
different architectures and poke at them
even simulation something that we're
working on of how do you simulate
certain scenarios and try to play that
out that's going to be awesome I don't
think you're writing base docs the same
way anymore because we can generate
basic documentation we need then the
smarter kind of more complicated docs
the integration scenario doc so I think
a lot of the toil the goal is the toil
goes away the things we don't really
like doing so for any of those roles you
could be a business analyst you could be
a tester an architect
I don't see how this is not trying to
strip away the toil yeah all right my
favorite use case for LMS right now is
actually to not only generate test data
but to you know string Escape so I can
then put in a CSV data prep that's
really where I've uh you know saved the
most time I always like to say that you
know the goal of these tools they're not
to replace you they're to accelerate
what you're doing so you can get to you
know the the more magic States quicker
okay so ask thought leaders up here on
stage
what are your largest concerns looking
forward and what would you recommend to
people as they're evaluating these tools
and where to go with this technology
manager
manage your relationship to Hype yeah
lower expectations I mean so it's better
to over deliver than under you're
expecting a 50 productivity Improvement
tomorrow you will be sadly disappointed
that's not how this works do not ignore
the marketing please
even ours you know all the all the
banking services we all use all Reliance
on Mainframe somewhere and the Mainframe
industry has been through waves and
waves of modernization aspirations and
modernizations have happened and
refactoring has happened but never
magically
and so we're going to go through that
cycle again with Gen Ai and of course
the ultimate destination is is to
refactor a code with AI I mean that's an
awesome destination and I know we will
aspire to that it's a big dream it's
great let's see what we can do
but as you pace yourself into that
Journey just take some baby steps first
and collect some benefits and learn I
mean there's a ton of change management
Associated to this that is not about the
potential of the technology but just
getting mindshare in your organization
so that people adopt it and and so on so
change management and temper your
temper the height
it's very Irwin answer anyone else want
to add on yeah I think for me uh my my
bigger concern is quality of the output
so
yeah these tools are great and we're
doing a lot with it at GE Appliances
within my team within product
development everything
but as probably everybody in this room
knows if you've messed with LMS at all
no matter what architecture you put in
place our AG pattern any of that you're
going to get hallucinations and my
concern is you know as as you say you
know hey there's going to be a lot of
new people coming in so we're gonna be
more courageous right and be that's
great I totally agree with you
I kind of Wonder though
what's going to happen with vetting the
outputs right there's going to have to
be humans in place still obviously
that's really looking at this output you
know did it really give me a right
architecture you know does it did it
really give me the right code or did it
write a you know a forever while loop
and then I didn't catch it right
something like that I mean you know I am
concerned about that the other thing
especially me being in an Enterprise
level
you know I'm having a lot of
conversations with security and
governance organization with you know
privacy pii we deal with a lot of pii
and we're very very concerned and very
serious about protecting that data and
protecting user input as they use AI
products that we're developing and tools
Etc even with NRS DLC within my team I'm
very concerned about what we're doing
with our data and where it's Landing I'm
very happy with Google's position to be
honest with you I'm glad you guys make
it very very clear that that data is
staying within the tenant it's not going
out it's not being you know trained in
the public model et cetera it's very
very important for us but that is a
concern yeah I'll see there's three
things that keep me up nothing keeps me
up really but the three things that
worry me with this first I don't want us
to stop hiring interns and Junior
employees because we think llms do the
work like I would have never gotten my
shot if someone had looked at this years
of experience we need people to give you
a chance at this stuff and I don't want
us to look at these models and say we
don't really need college hires anymore
we can just have llms do the junior work
no you want the junior work so those
folks become awesome senior tech people
so don't stop bringing new people in
that worries me that we're going to do
that same with this kind of touchdown we
cannot give up our expertise because
who's going to validate these things
this is not an excuse to get Dumber this
is kind of excuse to be like oh the
model will do it for me no this is an
excuse to know more and vet these models
and make sure that that's good python
code that's a valid sequel statement we
can't forget that right I'm not
interested in working for the model the
model still works for me so I just want
to make sure we don't give that up as
well and then the last one I think
there's a good breakout with the Wayfair
folks where they did a one of these
hackathons as well and they had really
good results the one score that was bad
was initially the people using gen AI
were actually more frustrated than the
ones who weren't and it was because they
were just kind of handed the tools and
the hackathon no training no prep and so
initially it was like what the heck's
going on it's generating stuff things
are happening they were ended up being
more productive everything else was
better
but I worry that we're just going to
shove this onto teams going I want 30
productivity by Friday let's go this is
going to be training this is going to be
a new way of working and so we can't
just treat this as an on off switch this
is a different way of working so I hope
that we hire great young people new
people in the market I hope that we kind
of think about how we train everybody
and then focus on expertise because we
need you all to be smart as ever not not
less yeah I mean how many times have you
had to you know migrate to another tool
as part of your your workflow and
were you happy about it yeah
uh if I could just add one yeah you
mentioned the word productivity a lot
right and
you know I think we need to be very real
about that that is that is coming that
that's here that is coming from you know
leadership from executive leadership Etc
who's looking at this and saying hey
why wouldn't you be 30 more productive
next year right and I think as Leaders
especially in your organizations it's
incumbent upon us to figure that out
yeah
it's it's not a play at you know hey
let's
stop hiring you know and all that kind
of stuff I'm not getting at that but
what I am getting at is these tools are
here
um we personally I'm seeing the
productivity uh capability out of this
and I do think it's important that we
that we work to figure that out how do
you measure that
yeah how do you know someone's
productive at GE yeah um so again uh I
think all of us in this room uh have to
be really careful about the metrics
right metrics can get crazy people game
the system Etc I've been in teams of hey
how many lines of code did you write you
know all this kind of stuff
I think we've all
dealt with that and maybe hopefully have
moved past that this is a new era it
really really is so for example
um uh unit test right so uh I I don't
know the exact name was it 20 30
something like that of time on unit
tests
can we get it to five uh can we shorten
our cycle times and our agile process
because of this I'm really looking at
the business requirement side I know how
much time it takes in my team to go from
business requirements to Pure technical
requirements and actually start work
it's 20 20 of our entire Project Life
Cycle is that I can measure that pretty
quick
so I'm going to be looking at that and
saying how can we reduce that and let's
just mob that and let's attack that and
let's figure it out
yeah there's actually something you said
earlier I actually want to talk a little
bit more about you brought up
hallucinations and you know I've been
walking around the Expo for seen a lot
of people in Industry you know
incorporate grounding into their
products so you know co-generation aside
do we have thoughts about you know
talking about grounding is this going to
be relevant next year at next
what do you think
well step one I think there is a great
opportunity to tune those models with
what you consider a good code base I
mean
you know Shameless plug I think we have
a session tomorrow morning about how you
can use the Kodi model to start doing
that type of thing
um
so I think that's step one just to try
to drive quality that you think matches
the standards of your organization then
you have citation that's super helpful
too
um but yeah grounding is making its way
in every gen AI conversation anyway
we we had a lot of conversation this
week with a lot of customers about
grounding whatever those models tell you
could be code or something else so that
you can try and draw a line between the
recommendation and some actual factual
reference so I think it's it's grounding
is a topic for Jenny as a whole not only
in this space yeah because I'd love to
hear if you have anything to add
I mean my favorite solution is execution
which I know is very hard to accomplish
but the truth is after you generated
software you can of course build you can
try to run integration tests end-to-end
testing
perhaps the vantage point or rapid is
you can execute on the spot and that is
for me the best way to give back feed
actual feedback to the user if the code
is correct or not I I do understand it
doesn't work in some of the use cases
we're talking about right now but it's
uh it's a good path forward for smaller
applications and yeah I do believe also
larger companies are gonna go in that
direction as well over time but
execution is expensive I'm aware
nice okay I think we'll have enough time
for maybe two more questions so we'll
wrap it up
oh this is my favorite question okay I
actually wrote this question first so
it's really easy to start with new code
right if you want to generate something
scratched with an empty file
but
what's harder is maintaining the Legacy
code base so do you have any thoughts on
innovation in this area
don't make me sing Legacy land
we humming that today uh
yeah look it is easier to start from
scratch I guess from there's no
technical debt you're dealing with it's
harder to match the business
requirements and things so sometimes it
makes sense to keep your legacy around
and improve it where it is you know
we've seen some good demonstrations as
well especially using duet to switch
from something like a C plus plus app to
a Go app and be able to change file by
file so I think that's a huge deal if we
can start taking advantage of upgrading
languages Frameworks it's no fun to move
from you know Java 8 to 17 and make
these different changes let alone go
from C to job I mean those are tough
moves so if Jenny I can make that easier
that seems like a giant win let alone
making the database changes like we've
talked about switching from one database
to another so this feels like this is
maybe the first time we have some really
legit tools and and using llms to make
that switch
at least to try it quickly sorry back to
your execution point it's we we dreamed
about those app modernization scenarios
for many years but between the day you
decide to try and the day you know it's
gonna pay off is it quite a long time
and here you can shorten that cycle and
kind of make up your mind okay this
sounds like a legit path so I think app
modernization will see will be Revisited
thanks to all of this sorry no no no
that's great
the only thing I wanted to add is it
depends on how Legacy is Legacy in the
sense that if you have to go back all
the way to Kabul and Fortran and we want
to you know to part that to something
modern there is literally not enough
code out there to make another lamp as
powerful as we need and by the way
migrations in general are far from being
an easy problem but we have to be
cognizant of the fact that real Legacy
is gonna take a lot of you know help of
Greece because you know Avalanche are
not that powerful in very old languages
so I'm much more excited about the like
the duet example from yesterday C plus
plus two python or like any other modern
language is way more attainable than you
know old school Finance systems which
are very hard to migrate and that's the
reason why they're still in Kabul today
yeah it might be frisky too I've tried
to go from go back to Cobalt
it works maybe we can finally rewrite
those poor train systems right the
longest project I was on at Google is
actually a three year rewrite from
python to go and you know we
we're at the source and it can still
take a long time yeah yeah
okay you know if I could add one thing
on a legacy side so
yeah Legacy code everybody has it we got
to deal with it and you know the
developer keynote out that was very
entertaining and awesome
um talking about Legacy I look at it in
a couple ways one I actually look at it
from the perspective of how fast can I
ramp up new hires in my team on our
Legacy code base
um I mean how long does that take today
for your teams right
um it can take a while right especially
if you have a large domain like you know
the platform I'm dealing with is is not
small by any means
we're looking at and we've started
integrating generative AI capabilities
across our code base to actually help
with documentation to help with
onboarding to help with ramp UPS
everything which just minimizes and
shortens that that ramp up time right so
I look at Legacy in that way we're going
to deal with Legacy you know conversions
I think the Kodi you know apis and stuff
do great job with that obviously the
demos installed duet I'm excited about
trying that but I'm really much more
excited about how generative AI is
helping with onboarding resources that's
such a killer point because arguably
that's what everybody in this room can
do right now is you can open up a file
in vs code have duet enabled and say
what does this file do yeah and get a
summary yeah I can take that gnarliest
weirdest query with 12 inner joins and
drop it in and go what does this query
do and you get an answer like that is
huge when I'm just trying to learn a
code base because that's very good I
can't go interview that developer who
retired three years ago right that's a
really good one yeah
I'm I'm excited to see when we can
really pull this up to like what does
this module do what does the service do
that's the next step right because when
you have to do these migrations it's
like doing surgery if you you aren't
precise you can really make some some
errors yeah you're a psychologist an
archaeologist if you're doing Legacy
stuff
okay
really this is my surprise question I
still haven't exited Bim on my laptop I
can take it out yeah
this could take one hour yeah I know
right are you sure you want to do this
next one Tabs are spaces or spaces yeah
let's start we'll start a fight up here
um are there any we have a few minutes
still so are there any other topics you
know based on our discussion that we had
today that we want to we want to discuss
any final thoughts you want to get out
yeah
look I I think maybe a
a lot of stuff for me would be
um
we've got to get in there and just play
with this stuff I mean we've got to give
the space for our teams to do that and
let them be Innovative you know we have
a
it's amazing like I just Unleashed my
team and just like hey just go innovate
with this right I gave him the time just
like go do it and they came up the most
amazing things right
um particularly around our hackathon and
outside of that I think that we really
if you're not doing that you got to
start doing that right
um and get just get in there and get
your hands dirty with this stuff and
you know figure out within your sdlc
what you need to do you know to to
improve it using general AI
maybe we can ask like how many of you in
your teams have had a time to just
explore how this can change your sdlc
like
a little bit yeah yeah maybe maybe
making time for that
yeah any leaders in the room I would say
carve out the time for your teams
say the other thing to be careful of is
I don't think we want to be here a year
from now whatever it is April when we do
the next one and you have to be do it on
purpose but if you go and buy Best of
breed things for every part of the sdlc
you still may be waking up in a year
with 12 different models that you are
training securing tuning maintaining I
don't think that's what you want to do
so if you're going to do it do it on
purpose but do think about like hey do
you want to take a platform approach are
there things that do SRE work and Dev
work are there things that can help me
with brainstorming and do other things
you might look for where I can do
multiple things with one or two or three
models so I just don't think you're
going to want to deal with a dozen of
them they'll have to be tuned separately
maintained separately we're absolutely
heading in that direction in a lot of
ways because there's an amazing
ecosystem of products and tools which
are awesome but just be intentional
about what you're doing there yeah I
didn't think we'd sip through those
questions so what other things are you
excited about that's coming soon
well I
I want to hear more of those stories
yeah you know it's all about we found
the part of the process we proved to
ourselves yeah that's great we're going
to be better at this I think this is
what matters honestly uh
for me it has to make sense in real life
the promise is why a lot of people agree
with it
I just want to see it happening so I'd
rather have you know dozens of people
saying this part of the like requirement
Gathering is where we've made the
difference having that would be better
than having a large crowd believing that
this may change their life someday I
think we need to get into it and pick
the pieces and and start thinking how do
I integrate that in the everyday life of
the developer that's what I'm excited
about the actual projects yeah and the
multiple pieces right because if we made
coding 50 better the average Dev spends
20 to 30 percent of their day coding so
I bet you've only fixed a third of their
a third of their day so you think about
can we improve the other parts the
unnecessary meetings you know the
testing stuff the fire fighting in prod
like when that stuff the whole sdlc gets
better that's when you might actually
get that 30 productivity Improvement
impossible from a coding assistant
that's why I'm not in sales but you're
not gonna that's not gonna happen you're
not gonna buy a coding assistant and
immediately be 30 better you're just you
don't code all day and so how can you
look a little wider and if you do that
absolutely you're going to be amazing he
even was just context switching this is
a metric that I know our engineering
productivity team at Google looks at
very quick uh very closely how many
times do we contact switch how can we
reduce that how can we get devs uh to
have a longer Flow State
that's right what is the three things we
measure we measure speed for developers
internally quality of their code and the
ease of their tools that's how Google
Engineers are measured so if you think
of the metrics around those things
that's this whole cycle that's not just
how fast you're in your IDE
a if you're interested in this in
particular uh the Google engineering
productivity research team has published
papers on you know what we track
internally uh they're very quantitative
uh it's very it's a really great read
well thank you everyone thank you thank
you
thank you
foreign